welcome to this video playing mandragora
Grandmaster and Shey blow from and forth
thailand yeah old friend of mine let's
see what we would we get here turns
Indian maybe i'm not sure what is
playing that with wider split all kinds
of moments ok so i remember he is
playing the exchange sometimes maybe we
get that yep
I recently saw this sacrificial idea 95
night XD 5 Wow now this is this is the
move I really wasn't aware mmm
interesting let's see what happens here
I always thought that 95 is going to
assist play 10 you take on e5 after c6
on it okay but we're not not i'm really
not saying that that I see something
greater or anything I just I was just
surprised okay so h6 is this one of
those lines where you play aged CH six
and g5 or how is this plate
we should hmm I can also maybe take on e
for the ship age four and take on you
phone case captured
we are 95 okay yeah if i take the snot
f6 threatened and there is c7 threatened
it's not easy to to address both take
take one c7 yeah i definitely have some
compensation but not clear to me how I
should play okay I really don't want to
take only five but I think I already
must do
Bishop to e6 oh yeah probably
you have I have active pieces I think
this was a bit loud I'm sorry I have
active pieces so i'm not i'm not totally
am pessimistic here but still not easy
cannot really take here because of
rookie one
I can also just take with the pawn this
is I basically didn't pay much attention
to that but I should have probably okay
let's hope I get enough count apply here
with be five I wonder about d6 maybe
this kind of drastic measures but I
should be able to take on c forum Oh is
just allowing the discovered check I
don't have a great check though check
hoping for 94 maybe rupee 894
yeah I took one to exchange this really
doomed check King bee 392 maybe
nitey talking before
check ya otherwise that didn't make I
could have taken I could have gone to d6
hmm maybe I should have should have
considered that time worrying him yeah
that's probably lost that's probably
knows the deep one is very very strong
in 92 this wasn't a very successful idn
I knew I could have taken and then go
here he's got the active King that's the
the whole or that's the real problem
here he's got this fantastic King
supporting the whole thing check
yeah jack is still as a winning position
even if he may overlook that but
probably they didn't I mean this is just
winning rugae 6 was like that no cat can
also resign him black resigns kind of
stuff is winning in his sleep it was a
very strange form of the exchange maybe
I made some move order an arrow here I
don't know I should take I should take
immediately this was my my my arrow am I
should take immediately this is this is
the whole program check
okay I cannot easily develop my Queens
ofc 6b five yeah this is okay this is
definitely okay or a5 a4 he has no one
no big big big idea to exploit this pin
I can just take them and this leads to
some trouble even before was good before
I was thinking here but this is a
disaster like it's plus for chaya I'm
compulsion to hear I didn't understand
the thought you can go here an IDF to I
overlooked that of course it's still a
good position for white because of the
pawns especially the depot is strong but
check okay well around here probably
Jack I'm probably toast check yeah this
is lost minus three so I should avoid
all those problems by playing 90-84 am I
saw the move but just a bit too late
after I played age six and he are
already in trouble this is not a good
position okay thanks for watching